hey guys it's justine and i'm here with
ro hello so we filmed a really fun video
on her channel
and i'm so excited because after that we
came over here again
to do something very very fun okay so i
recently went to disney
yeah and i had him to disney in over a
year and a half like i used to have an
annual pass like we used to go all the
time
we went that one time disney's pack like
it's back
they also have the star wars galaxy's
edge so i never had gone jenna had gone
to the press event
and was able to like ride the rides and
go see everything so i never got to see
it and they have this thing it's savvy's
workshop where you can make
a freaking lightsaber
so yeah so i have two of them here so
you kind of go in and you get to pick
what kind of saber you want when you go
in they give you one of these
pins so that you know like which camp
you're in
and then they give you the pieces for it
so like it's this whole thing
it's a whole thing it's a whole thing so
we need to go back and do this again but
i brought the sabers today
i haven't even actually got to see them
outside of disney
so they're huge yes i mean they're
massive they're these are not like
little dinky
these are huge sabers here i feel like
you're about to pull out a sword
basically so this was the one that was
peace and justice so it's crazy because
they give you all of these pieces
and then you put it together yourself
yeah you get to choose the color crystal
so here's the crystals
i lost my mind because after you make
this they then take you into like a
little workshop area
and then you can buy like extra crystals
oh that's cool
yeah so this is yoda's crystal
i think this one i think ahsoka had this
one
and obviously like luke and obi-wan had
the blue
and this other one i chose the purple
this is cool oh my gosh look little
yoda it's so cool okay this one is
this one's really aggressive check this
one out
okay okay let's see it
that's cool it makes noise
it does you know i've been doing like
lightsaber training
yes okay well these are not gonna do
this these are not ones that you fight
with these are like the
these are these are art pieces do you
wanna hold it
oh my gosh it's got weight to it like
this is like the real
d wow i know oh
oh wow it's heavy oh yeah that's a
workout okay are there any colors
which do do you remember any colors of i
don't want to say the bad guys but yeah
like it's usually red bad guys
a lot of red yeah so they're usually
always red so they these little crystals
here
the crystals yeah so these open up
and this get out of there little dude
so there's a little crystal shut up
that's so cool
so this goes inside of the saber and
that's how
you change the color so i lost my mind
incredible this is so incredible do you
know
what color do you think you would want
your savor to be probably not red
i mean i could rock it but i don't think
i'd be a red
i'm not really about that empire i'm
more i'm more of a rebel
yeah i think i would probably do a pink
i don't think anybody has a pink i mean
the closest color i guess would be the
purple
oh my gosh oh i don't know how i just
did that justine
that's okay this little bucket right
here
okay i haven't never had any jedi
training for lightsaber training
so i don't know what i'm doing today you
will
so inside here they also have pre-made
ones
of basically like every jedi and of
course i love rey
so i had to buy a raised lightsaber i
haven't even opened it yet
this is really exciting they're there oh
look at this this is fancy
oh shoot this is that looks really
really
really nice this is even cooler than
these ones actually
i feel like it's way nicer than these
and these are really nice
wow oh my gosh
oh wow right wow that's like actual like
real it's heavy duty we can't actually
fight with these because these are more
just kind of like props like okay these
look cool yeah we need what are stump
savers
a stunt saver so i uh these ones we use
to actually like
hit each other with so i was thinking
maybe we could go in the backyard and
you know test it out yes okay yes
teach me some lightsaber skills because
i have not
i feel how light this is like this is so
much lighter than these ones
oh yeah should we should we go outside
okay oh gosh
[Music]
okay ro we are outside now this is
really fun like
basically this kind of stems from a
couple different martial arts
both staff spinning collie which is like
a filipino martial arts which usually
kept like two sticks but
then when my trainer was like hey we
should do lightsaber training i was like
why didn't you tell me that this was a
thing
so we've been doing this and it's really
fun so there's a bunch of like different
moves i think i'll probably
show off a little bit show me some stuff
too you know we'll just do a little of
this
whoa you know just
just a little bit of just a little
savoring the basic thing that you want
to get down
is like this simple little move right
here what you do
so just kind of roll your wrist a little
you're just kind of like letting it go
so it's kind of going between like your
two fingers
you got it is this it yeah you're doing
it
down yeah uh that's good okay
and then you're gonna want to kind of do
one of these well well
i'm a really bad teacher whoa whoa okay
show me what you just did
so you're doing this you're doing the
flipping and then you're gonna do one of
these and bring it around and then back
again behind your back yeah so i don't
really know how to explain it
okay do it again do it again let me see
we're doing this we're doing this we're
doing this
and then it comes around and then you're
kind of flinging your
elbow in front of you one more one more
whoa
it looks awesome i don't know what i'm
doing
like a look at this i don't know how to
even do it again do it again okay
back here see if you're back here okay
so it's like
it's coming in front of you but you're
kind of leading with this elbow
and then you come out okay wait oh i
think i just did it wait a minute
[Music]
i just did it i don't know what i did
but i think i do it again
i don't know what i did i don't either i
got this lead with the elbow
the elbow
i've sliced off everyone's legs and my
own so
there's different angles and each angle
has a number
okay okay so one one two
two three three four
four and then a five is a nice thrust to
the belly
five six six seven
seven and eight eight and it gets a
little confusing because sometimes yeah
it can also be a six oh this can also
be a seven so it's kind of just those
uppercut angles upper
upper so now i'm going to come at you
with a one and then you can just kind of
block it
like you know there you go like this
yeah okay so you can either do
one-handed or two-handed or two-handed
yeah
so yeah okay now you flip to the other
side
okay okay we're fighting
we're fighting we did it
like you're gonna be a jedi oh you know
this is for men
okay so the teacher will block hit me
like that so you oh okay you got it so
i'm coming in
yep so you just want to step off to the
side and just kind of do an overhead
block
okay so go ahead and give me another
eight okay
and then you come back
okay
okay now i'm gonna come in i'm gonna i'm
gonna give you one of the overhead
eights
all right get ready to block it
i love it yeah you just wanna block that
okay guys give you one more ready ready
ready
oh yeah
okay okay right here okay okay
ready okay okay now i'm coming in
well bro i think that for your first
class yeah
you did really well thanks jose you're a
great teacher
no i'm not i'm actually an incredibly
terrible teacher no you did really great
you taught me how to do the wrist thing
and behind my back
yeah we've got some other tricks maybe
next time we can do like a passing
in the back okay show me that again one
more try okay okay i think you can do
this one more
so you're just kind of doing your spin
and then you're going to cool
how the heck did you do that what are
these called stunt sabers oh gosh
myself well guys thank you so much for
watching ro thank you so much for being
in this video
this was so fun this is amazing i love
this
i want to do more of this i will get my
trainer and then we'll start
doing some jedi training okay okay cool
make sure you go check out ro's channel
we do some fun videos over there so go
subscribe
check out her videos and we will see you
guys in our next video
so yeah bye five five may the force be
with you
[Music]
uh
you